aquí en el Eliseo hay actores y actrices
de nuestra acción colectiva en el
continente africano y a sumo plenamente
expresarme antes de esta gira aquí en
París ante ustedes para darle un sentido
a todo lo que estamos tratando de hacer
hace ya un poco más de cinco años para
decir con quién Por qué Y cómo en el
fondo del objetivo que tenemos es el de
tener una política más simple más
legible
para que trabajen todas las
administraciones del estado
y también para tener una política que
asocie plenamente a los empresarios a
luz generadores a los deportistas los
artistas los científicos que todos
participen en esta política que no es
simplemente de gobierno a gobierno sino
que quiere asumir plenamente un tratado
con la sociedad tratar con la sociedad
civil de todos los países de África en
el fondo aquí estamos reunidos varios
actores de nuestra política con África
muchos de los cuales me acompañar me
acompañaran en esta Gira a partir del
miércoles o que me han acompañado en
viajes anteriores hace unos seis años en
noviembre del 2017 no no auditorio de la
Universidad de aguadul
cité las palabras de Tomás zancada
diciendo también que ya no había una
política africana de Francia y estas
palabras siguen siendo actuales pero ya
no son suficientes teniendo en cuenta
las transformaciones profundas que se
han vivido estos últimos años el tiempo
pasado en el continente africano es
irremplazable he hecho 17 viajes me han
recibido 21 países
desde lagos y las
múltiples entrevistas con muchos
personajes africanos y en todo el mundo
no hay una consideración general puesto
que no existe
una unidad africana sino en muchos
esquemas simplificadores la única
exigencia es que hagamos muestra de una
profunda humildad con respecto a lo que
sucede en el continente africano una
situación sin precedentes en la historia
y de manera urgente muchos retos retos
climáticos retos demográficos
la juventud que está llegando y a la
cual hay que ofrecerle un futuro para
cada uno de los estados africanos
consolidar estados de administraciones
invertir masivamente en educación salud
empleo formación transición energética
todo esto
con la presión del cambio climático y
sus efectos también la presión de la
ofensiva terrorista y los problemas
sanitarios
ninguna Región del mundo ha estado
sometida a esta obligación de resultados
en el espacio de una o dos generaciones
como lo ha sido el continente africano
como lo está haciendo hoy por esta razón
antes de mi gira por el continente
africano ya les dije que la prioridad no
es hacer un nuevo discurso en suelo
africano sino intentar de la manera más
clara posible defender lo que estamos
haciendo allí
explicar la coherencia de nuestra acción
y fortalecer
otra visión de África y Francia
por eso están aquí presentes nuestros
artistas y nuestros deportistas También
colectivamente tenemos que evaluar los
retos que tenemos frente a nosotros no
para ser predicciones apocalípticas ni
para sembrar el pánico algo que he visto
en mis viajes
África no es una tierra de resignación
sino de optimismo esta energía debe
inspirarnos y debe movernos a realizar a
darnos cuenta de que somos vecinos de
África y de que somos uno de los países
que tienen un vínculo único humano y
existencial con este continente Esta es
una suerte para nosotros tenemos un
destino común con nuestros amigos
africanos Si queremos aprovechar esta
oportunidad tenemos que acercarnos más a
este continente que además
progresivamente será uno de los mercados
más dinámicos del mundo y uno de los
grandes hogares del crecimiento
económico mundial uno de los grandes
focos del crecimiento económico mundial
nuestra juventud aquí escucha música del
Congo de Nigeria música producida en el
continente africano y es la
prefiguración de un crecimiento cultural
económico político científico africano
que seguirá
desplegándose también nuestro
crecimiento económico en Europa y
nuestros empleos dependen cada vez más
de África Esta no es una noticia ni
buena ni mala simplemente es un hecho y
todo dependerá de lo que hagamos
por eso estoy convencido de que ha
llegado el momento de tomar una decisión
y de saber cuál es la relación que
queremos tener con los países africanos
y en el fondo
yo trato de seguir la actualidad lo hago
con frecuencia Cuando veo cuál es la
calificación del momento que estamos
viviendo que es claramente
un intermedio porque tenemos en este
momento varias dificultades históricas
estamos en un momento de transición y no
nos hemos dado cuenta realmente cuando
ha comenzado esta transición tenemos que
entrar en una competencia es como la
primera vía pero es una competencia que
a mí me parece anacrónica es la trampa
que corresponde
entrar a este reto del crecimiento
algunos llegan con sus ejércitos y sus
mercenarios aquí o allá y nos dicen
vengan ustedes Este es el papel de
ustedes vengan a competir con ellos aquí
los esperamos pero yo no creo eso
esa es la lectura que se hacía en el
pasado
nuestras operaciones militares eran algo
pero tenemos vínculos privilegiados con
algunos
dirigentes
antes la relación era diferente pero
este tiempo ya pasó antes nos creíamos
en el centro de todo pero la situación
hoy es diferente
Ahora
vemos una época nostálgica y por eso
desde el 2017 quisimos adoptar un nuevo
camino
es la crónica de nuestra última década
de compromisos En Mali al precio de
sacrificios últimos allí en nuestros
soldados junto a los militares marianos
y los ejércitos africanos enfrentaron a
los grupos terroristas aquí quiero
rendir homenaje a la memoria de nuestros
soldados de nuestros heridos y a los que
perecieron allá
está Este es un orgullo compartido con
los aliados que nos acompañaron en esa
operación
Pero ese no era el papel de nuestros
soldados
cuando debías sola aportar respuestas
políticas que vivían
seguir después de la respuesta militar a
pesar de nosotros asumimos una
responsabilidad exorbitante
es el objeto por amalgama una clase
política de Madrid que no ha logrado
recuperar su país y estos riesgos
podrían reproducirse en otras partes por
eso nunca dejaré que el sacrificio de
nuestros militares se vean manchados con
esa amalgana no quiero que
esta situación se reproduzca no quiero
que haya una engranaje de sustituciones
para que hagan que hagan que Francia se
convierta en un chivo expiatorio para
evitar que la historia se repita hay
otra vía es otra vía que estamos
caminando desde hace seis años ya no
queremos entrar en competencia ni en una
idea de renta sino que ahora queremos
ser tener una relación
con los países con quienes tenemos
responsabilidades compartidas queremos
una relación equilibrada recíproca y
responsable Este es el rumbo que se fijó
en
2017 y lo Hemos cumplido Hemos cumplido
nuestros compromisos con nuestros
compromisos frente a Ruanda en Argelia
en Camerún con una comisión de entre
Francia y camerón que comenzará pronto
también nos Hemos cumplido reformando el
francés f1
también apoyando la moneda africana
que podrá prefigurar una moneda única
que quizás cambie de nombre estamos
listos para esto Hemos cumplido nuestros
compromisos al apoyar frente a la
pandemia del covid 19 la Excelencia
científica africana el centro de crisis
africana El Instituto pastor de acá del
instituto nacional de investigación
biológica del profesor
a quien visitaré en estos días y también
desarrollando centros de producción
vacunas como lo hicimos en Sudáfrica y
en algunos otros países cumplimos
nuestros compromisos en materia
deportiva
creando nuevas asociaciones para formar
deportistas en el continente africano y
desplegando infraestructuras deportivas
lo haremos desde el fútbol judo basket y
otros deportes Hemos cumplido nuestros
compromisos acelerando gracias a la
tenacidad
para cambiar la mirada de Francia hacia
el continente africano Incluso en
nuestras escuelas y nuestros manuales
escolares Seguiremos este movimiento de
reconexión
y en Francia será la misión de la de la
casa de los mundos africanos que
organizaron foros sobre las Industrias
culturales y creativas de África en el
continente africano serán nuestros
institutos culturales nuestra red de
cooperación nuestras alianzas francesas
volverán a ser El Crisol de esta
intimidad entre Francia y África y para
que impulsen este cambio de mirada
nuestros institutos recibirán a todo el
mundo y tomaremos todos los riesgos
serán los lugares donde empiezan a
irradiar
los pintores que
le dan fuerza a esta red y esta red
fuerte es la que queremos seguir
teniendo los compromisos de
Google
los Hemos cumplido gracias a los al
trabajo de los equipos del
lee los trabajos realizados en peñín e
iremos más
que propondremos una ley marco la
ministra de cultura
pondrá una ley marco ante nuestro
parlamento también el trabajo realizado
por Martínez a quien agradezco esta ley
marco
permitirá fijar con nuestra
representación nacional la metodología y
Los criterios para proceder a una nueva
devolución a los países africanos que
deseen que se les devuelvan sus obras
estas obras de todas maneras serán
conservadas con nuestro apoyo queremos
que haya una dinámica más amplia y una
dinámica europea a la imagen del frente
Franco alemán que desarrollamos que que
lanzamos para desarrollar la
investigación
del arte en nuestras colecciones también
hemos apoyado
esa relación
con África
desarrollando la iniciativa todos
africanos
buscaremos empresarios franceses y
africanos que viven una situación de
riesgo y que no han podido acceder a
créditos que les permitan continuar Ese
es el objetivo de africana 2
es para acompañar a quienes tienen
proyectos de mayor riesgo también será
nuestro banco Público de inversión y la
agencia francesa de desarrollo que
lanzarán un nuevo programa todos África
dos que se dedicará este esfuerzo y que
en particular en materia de cultura
deporte agricultura y todas las
aspectos digital todo esto es para
aumentar las oportunidades
disminuiremos el riesgo de las
inversiones En África y aceleraremos el
crecimiento de las pequeñas empresas
africanas que están entre la economía
formal e informal
esto ya ha sido un éxito en senegal
luego haremos en otros países africanos
y desarrollaremos una política de
innovación con todos los países que lo
deseen También en estos últimos años
planteamos las bases de un eje
euroafricano que se encarnó en la Cumbre
de Bruselas en febrero del 2022 bajo la
presidencia francesa y con base en este
eje euroafricano logramos en París en
mayo de 2021
en la Cumbre de París sobre la
financiación de las economías africanas
El rey despliegue de los Derechos
especiales de giro en favor de África
por eso Sé que cuento con el compromiso
del comisario
que nos acompañarán a la República
democrática del Congreso queremos
Establecer un verdadero equipo europeo
este cuadro general
me permite decir que estos últimos años
hemos transformado profundamente lo que
parecían unos grandes tabúes
en la universidad de todos los
estudiantes que me hacían preguntas me
hablaban del francés como lengua como
primera lengua de la del acompañamiento
de las empresas africanas bien todo esto
lo hemos establecido durante estos
últimos años con mucho compromiso de
todas maneras no podemos perder nuestra
lucidez
la situación Por ahora es poco cómodas
estamos todavía con el pasado que nos
pesa tenemos una política que ha
decidido cambiar y que a veces ha
perdido apoyos que eran útiles
porque queríamos cambiar de método pero
todavía no tenemos los resultados plenos
de la política nueva que lanzamos por
eso todavía dependemos del pasado y
todavía no estamos completamente
convencidos de nuestro futuro por eso la
gira de la próxima semana es muy
importante es en un momento en donde
estamos cerrando un ciclo de nuestra
historia en África un ciclo que estuvo
marcado En mi opinión por dos cosas que
vamos a cambiar
marcado en el fondo
primero por la centralidad del asunto de
seguridad y el tema militar y la
prevención de la seguridad como marco de
todo y esta preeminencia el papel que
siguió teniendo Durante los años pasados
pretexto que utilizaron muchos de
quienes se oponen a nosotros
y lo usaron para hacer su propia
propaganda decían que Francia seguía
teniendo una agenda de seguridad y el
objetivo de esta fase en la que estamos
entrando esta nueva era es
desplegar en forma de relación nuestra
presencia de seguridad pero para que se
inserte en esta nueva relación Agradezco
al ministro del ejército el jefe de
Estado Mayor de los ejércitos por el
trabajo hecho en los últimos años por
haber pensado y preparar esta nueva
relación de seguridad de esto hablaré
más adelante y el segundo compromiso es
pasarse una lógica de ayuda a una lógica
de inversión solidaria y de
relacionamiento
pienso que esta es la condición
continuando la acción que ya fue lanzada
así es como podremos conjurar primero
esta oposición que se está instalando
entre
global que ya no tienen un software
común pienso profundamente que esto es
falso y lo hemos demostrado con un
método nuevo que lanzamos el g7 de
viajes fue preparado con los países
africanos también se hizo en el g20 de
balín donde reunimos a todos los países
africanos antes de comenzar las
reuniones
Tuvimos una conversación permanente y lo
mismo habíamos hecho cuando lanzamos la
iniciativa acta fue concebida con todos
los países africanos en un diálogo que
habías que era inédito y es lo mismo que
haremos ahora vamos a consolidar esta
lógica ese paso de la lógica de ayuda a
la de la inversión solidaria durante la
Cumbre que vamos a organizar el 23 de
junio en París sobre la nueva relación
entre el norte y el sur precisamente
porque es con África pero también con
india con Barbados con todos ellos
podremos inventar un nuevo pacto una
nueva arquitectura financiera
internacional para luchar contra las
desigualdades financieras y la
transición y financiar la transición
climática este momento que estamos
creando ahora consiste en ir hasta el
final del cambio y ser exigentes con
nosotros mismos y aceptar
soltar los reflejos y los hábitos y a
Incluso el lenguaje que hoy en día nos
hacen
daño no nos dejan avanzar y ahora
adoptar una postura más clara de
modestia de escucha Y de ambición es
decir es decir claramente en todos estos
Campos que África no es un territorio
exclusivo que tampoco es un continente
en el cual los europeos y los franceses
podrían dictar un marco de desarrollo
sino que es un continente En donde
podemos construir relaciones respetuosas
equilibradas y responsables para luchar
conjuntamente por causas comunes el
clima una muy importante
para defender nuestros intereses y para
ayudar a los países africanos a salir
adelante y tener éxito Esos son los
términos mismos De esta nueva relación
que queremos instaurar
y que es totalmente la inversa de las
lógicas de depredación ya sea de
seguridad o militar o financiera que
otros países están impulsando hoy en día
como lo decía para tener éxito en este
modelo de relación tenemos primero que
todo que construir un nuevo modelo de
relación militar este es todo el trabajo
que hemos hecho en los últimos meses
diseñandolo y discutiéndolo y
trabajándolo con nuestros
socios africanos
fueron invitados acá el ministro de
y por eso organizamos esta gira para
continuarlo ya no hablamos de las bases
militares como existen hoy mañana
nuestra presencia se inscribirá
en las escuelas en las academias
congestionadas habrá personas Francés
pero
en menor cantidad y personal áfricano y
si nuestros amigos africanos lo desean
podrán recibir otros socios de acuerdo
con los intercambios que he tenido esta
semana con mis homólogos esta
transformación comenzará en los próximos
meses con base en el principio mismo de
la construcción con una disminución
visible de nuestros efectivos y de
manera simultánea Un aumento de nuestros
Un aumento de la
presencia de nuestros socios en África
luego podremos aumentar nuestra oferta
de formación de acompaña de equipamiento
todo en el mejor nivel
y esta nueva relación nos permitirá
construir un nuevo modelo de intimidad y
de implicación entre nuestros ejércitos
que se traducirá por un mayor esfuerzo
de Francia en materia de formación y de
equipamiento
en segundo lugar esta nueva relación
está transformación supone que cambiemos
nuestra manera de hacer y de
comunicarnos con respecto a lo que
hacemos primero siendo más reactivos más
visibles y más invisibles tenemos que
asumir nuestras fracasos pero también
tenemos que asumir mejor nuestros éxitos
y debemos constatar que tenemos un
defecto nosotros en Francia estamos muy
divididos y esta lógica de boutique a
veces prevalece sobre la del equipo de
Francia tenemos que actuar todos juntos
para que todo esto sea legible y
cualquiera que sea la entidad ya sea
administrativamente o las todo esto debe
aportar soluciones concretas para
responder a una necesidad de la juventud
para educar mejor para responder a
problemas energéticos y de transición
climática para responder a los
deportistas por eso es el equipo de
Francia el que debe trabajar pero
estamos divididos no somos muy concretos
no somos muy legibles por eso
Próximamente Tendremos que cambiar
nuestros métodos desplegar proyectos más
concretos y tangibles y es allí donde
nuestros socios y amigos nos esperan en
el campo de la educación Pero no solo
construyendo muros sino aumentando
nuestra oferta de formación de los
docentes
ofreciendo una oferta de formación
profesional que lo piden muchos países
en incluso algunos donde no estábamos
muy presentes formación profesional
salud clima igualdad de géneros
empresariado
mundo digital cultura simplificar
nuestra oferta y estar siempre a la
escucha trabajar más con la sociedad
civil y aportar una oferta que sea de la
mejor calidad posible y hacerlo con el
con nuevo reflejos
bajar a la arena como lo hicimos en la
Cumbre de montpellier decidiendo
escuchar a la juventud y a la sociedad
civil africana como lo hizo la ministra
delegada en sus diferentes giras en
estos últimos meses cosa que le
agradezco y también embarcar con
nosotros a todos los demás y cada vez
que sea útil jugar como europeos o
incluso como internacionales que es
exactamente lo que haremos en estos
próximos días con una postura colectiva
para 40 millones de euros que serán
puestos a disposición en los países
francófonos de África para demostrar que
podemos hacer esta transformación y es
la misión que tendrán nuestros
Embajadores y embajadoras demostrar que
nuestra relación es concreta y que hay
una ofensiva sin complejos pero sin
arrogancia
También tenemos que ir hasta el final en
esta transformación porque tenemos
intereses que defender cuando se habla
de África hay que decirlo claramente
porque es mucho mejor si las cosas se
dicen
no vamos a hacer el bien común tenemos
un reto como en el cambio climático es
un reto común Buscar que la juventud
africana tenga un futuro claro es un
reto común pero vamos a defender
intereses y eso es lo que es una
relación recíproca y equilibra es decir
que no se toma al otro como un imbécil
no no no es que vamos a llegar a su país
para hacer el bien será que ustedes no
son capaces no eso ya no es así vamos a
defender nuestros intereses con
respetando los intereses de los países
africanos A dónde vamos a estar desde el
comienzo el consejo presidencial para
África
siempre ha pensado así en el despliegue
de sus propuestas y gracias a todos sus
miembros bueno primero la democracia
Francia es un país que en África y en
otras partes apoya la democracia y la
libertad es un país que le habla a todos
incluso a los opositores políticos un
país que prefiere las instituciones
sólidas a los hombres providenciales un
país que considera que los golpes
militares nunca serán la alternancia
democrática y como lo recuerdan muchos
intelectuales africanos la democracia
también tiene una juventud africana por
eso nuestro papel no es imponer nuestros
valores ni proclamarlos sino contribuir
a que haya redes de intelectuales y
actores cívicos que le den vida
inspirándose en las prácticas
democráticas
ese será el papel de la fundación sobre
la innovación y la democracia que
creamos a finales del año pasado en
johannesburgo y que se irradiará en todo
el continente para esto Agradezco al
profesor
sus hijos y sus propuestas y por todo lo
que ya ha construido con sus equipos
esto lo continuaremos haciendo Y ese
haciendo Y ese es el principio de lo que
vamos a hacer en general
está el interés de Francia que es la
democracia pero hay que trabajar en
medio del respeto hay que tener en
cuenta la historia del continente y los
actores nuestro interés también es tener
una nueva ambición económica en el
continente africano nuestra relación
económica con el continente africano es
sólida Sí pero lo digo aquí y me alegro
de la presencia de una delegación
numerosa
de economistas de grandes calidades
agradezco a todos ellos su presencia hoy
aquí
pero necesitamos ser lúcidos con
respecto a la nuestra a nuestra
presencia económica en el continente
africano
estamos en una posición que no
está tomando la dirección correcta y en
parte es nuestra falta porque muchas
veces hemos tenido la lógica de renta en
nuestra relación con el continente
africano consideramos que como éramos
Francia incluso cuando cuando nos
equivocamos incluso cuando nuestros
productos eran más costosos y nuestra
financiación menos buena pensábamos que
debíamos ser aceptados hay quienes hacen
la competencia con otras armas Claro
está
a veces la financiación se vuelve
también un elemento de debilidad Pero
bueno independientemente de todo esto lo
digo porque lo he visto hoy todavía
muchas de nuestras empresas no producen
trabajos de la mejor calidad solo porque
están en África
pero eso ya no será más así y lo digo
con toda sinceridad ya no seguiré
defendiendo las empresas que no quieren
luchar Cuando un presidente de la
república va a un país o recibe a un
dirigente
y no hay respeto en cuanto a los niveles
O sea no es lo mismo cuando vamos a
Alemania Polonia o sea hoy en día África
es una tierra de competencia tenemos que
cambiar el modelo económico francés para
decir allí tenemos que ir a luchar
un contrato siempre
debe respetar los tiempos y la calidad
a veces también debemos reconocer que
nuestros socios africanos tampoco están
a la altura y hay que decirlo o sea nos
cuesta trabajo decir que nosotros no
estamos a la altura tenemos que hacer
Entonces un trabajo colectivo para
lograr este equilibrio hay otros países
que no están mejor armados que nosotros
están tomando posiciones porque toman en
serio a los países africanos deseo
también que una nueva generación de
empresarios franceses y africanos Franco
africanos se proyecten nuevas
cooperaciones ya sean una nueva
filosofía que debe ser la de la
coindustrialización
es el sentido mismo del programa pasa
África algunos laureados están aquí
presentes es un programa muy importante
que nos va a permitir desarrollar
esa
reunión de empresas es para ayudar a los
nuevos actores la nueva lógica es ayudar
a los nuevos actores Y de alguna manera
sacar provecho de una manera muy
pragmática del hecho de que Francia
tiene esa fuerza
y que hay empresarios en África y que su
propia conexión debe ayudarlos a
desplegar sus actividades y su éxito en
ese continente
También tenemos el interés de actuar
colectivamente con nuestros aliados
europeos y posicionar Europa como el
como el socio de referencia en varios
temas tema de seguridad que es el
corazón mismo de lo que vamos a hacer
más allá del
hace un momento También queremos hacerlo
en materia de financiamiento de las
infraestructuras africanas solo con esta
palanca podremos realmente jugar con
armas iguales varios de ustedes están
comprometidos en este sector y les
agradezco y lo hacen muy seriamente pero
es con esa palanca podremos convencer a
nuestros socios africanos que adopten
los estándares con los cuales nuestras
empresas podrán producir las
infraestructuras de calidad todo esto
dentro del marco del g20 es la lógica de
lo que hizo la Unión Europea con el
global y que llevamos al g7 también con
la sociedad mundial por las de las
infraestructuras algo que se desplegará
de aquí a 2027 son inversiones masivas
pero el marco del g20 es un marco de
seriedad de sostenibilidad de la
financiación pública de todas estas
infraestructuras Por eso tenemos que
viajar juntos hablar juntos actuar
juntos siempre que hemos movilizado este
europeo euroafricano
hemos estado a la altura de nuestras
promesas También tenemos ventajas que
tenemos que hacer valer
nuestra investigación científica
nuestras universidades nuestras empresas
nuestros artistas nuestros deportistas
nuestros jóvenes que trabajan en
voluntariado y como lo dije hace un
momento nuestra diáspora cada uno de
ustedes se podrá reconocer en esta lista
la buena noticia
es que en el fondo son ustedes más que
el presidente de la república los que
son esperados en África Ese es el
mensaje Claro que fue dado en el en la
Cumbre de monteville este es el mensaje
que he oído en todas partes en África
Incluso en julio pasado cuando dialogué
con varios camerunenses algunos de
ustedes me acompañaban
todos preguntan Dónde está la juventud
francesa en esta nueva relación Dónde
están las universidades francesas por
qué
el equipo de Francia de fútbol van a
jugar a todas partes del mundo pero
nunca en África por qué no trabajan más
con nosotros por eso es que
ustedes tienen que estar conmigo
acompañarme porque yo solo No tengo las
respuestas a todas estas preguntas
hay que dar una respuesta creíble y
durable
y esta respuesta la llevaremos
lo que estamos haciendo desde hace seis
años es importante no solamente para
nuestros nuestros intereses en África
sino también para dar las respuestas a
estos desafíos africanos es algo que
seguramente Tendremos que hablar en
libro el tema climático la diversidad de
los bosques pero es importante para
Francia también
esta nueva relación será un éxito si
asumimos la parte de africanidad de
Francia el papel
que ocupan la diáspora y sabemos que
Francia ya no tiene un territorio
exclusivo en Francia Ahora tiene deberes
tiene intereses tiene amistades que
quiere construir para continuar y
reforzar para adoptar políticas sólidas
en cada uno de los campos que todos
ustedes representan aquí Ese es el
sentido de esta gira y del trabajo que
haremos dentro de los Durante los
próximos cuatro años
asumir estos intereses establecer lazos
humanos más fuertes reforzar el vínculo
con la sociedad civil y construir
conjuntamente una agenda sobre los temas
climáticos de Educación y de salud que
sean buenos para todos nosotros vínculos
económicos universitarios académicos
culturales deportivos no tengo ninguna
nostalgia de lo que fue la Francia
África
pero
quiero que esto cambie ustedes serán el
núcleo de esta relación y su propio
compromiso le dará todo el sentido a las
decisiones políticas que hemos tomado
con nuestro parlamento de realzar y
santuarizar esta política de relación
También con financiamientos inéditos
esta política no es una política de
instrumentos desencarnados no es una
política de solidaridad también es una
política para los francesas para
permitirnos encontrar socios y aliados
para tener una influencia en los
equilibrios del mundo si tenemos éxito
en junio próximo está cumbre de la nueva
relación entre el norte y el sur
Así es como podremos conjurar este gran
relato que se está instalando
la doble Norma que se está instaurando
dentro de Ucrania y el resto del mundo
una división entre el mundo y El Gran
Sur si dejamos que
esto se sale O si lo documentamos para
un país o para otro Será algo terrible
porque como lo decía al principio
lo que es Francia y nuestra geografía es
el futuro
bueno Muchas gracias por su atención
voy a
contestar primero las preguntas de los
periodistas Y si la delegación también
tiene preguntas también las responderé
[Aplausos]
primera pregunta de un periodista desde
la sala
Buenos días señor presidente Gracias
porque este discurso tuvo lugar aquí en
París y no en África Francia tiene acaso
miedo de hablarles a los africanos desde
su propio continente pero es una pequeña
pregunta la más importante es esta
Francia depende sus valores ha hablado
de democracia de libertad con frecuencia
Francia ha condenado la intangibilidad o
la violación a la tangibilidad de las
fronteras como es el caso actualmente
mediante la relación e internacionales
independientes para Ruanda o la
República democrática del Congo el
presidente Félix dijo esta mañana en
Ginebra
de derechos del hombre pidió sanciones
Francia se demoró en condenar cuatro
años se demoró Francia para pasar a las
sanciones como lo hizo con la comunidad
internacional
para Rusia presente en Ucrania bueno
gracias a usted en su primera pregunta
creo que mi introducción había
respondido
aquí quería teniendo en cuenta la
importancia de esta política para
Francia pues me parecía importante
hacerlo aquí mismo en París porque no
solamente hay que hablar de Francia
cuando estamos allá sino también antes
de comenzar esto muestra una actitud
solemne esto muestra que también es
importante para nosotros lo segundo
bueno es una discusión
como antes de un partido es bueno hablar
con todos antes
digamos yo ya empecé a hablar con la
juventud africana y lo seguiré haciendo
en cuanto al Ruanda primero hay que
darle nombre a las cosas
democrática del Congo o sea en el este
del Congo
Hay una regresión que es inaceptable la
ofensiva en curso
m23 con sanción del Consejo de Seguridad
es una guerra que nos devuelve hacia el
pasado 10 años tiene terribles
consecuencias para la población sobre
todo los cientos de miles de desplazados
que no tienen nada y la capital de la
región goma está amenazada la primera
emergencia es humanitaria y estamos
trabajando con nuestros socios europeos
varias ocasiones
con los presidentes
sobre el tema también hay que recordar
dos principios fundamentales la unidad
la soberanía la integridad territorial
del Congo no se discuten
es nuestra posición constante y esta
posición no ha cambiado
en segundo lugar no hay un despliegue de
medidas la guerra en el este de la rdc
no debe ser una guerra olvidada por eso
he hablado tanto tiempo con cada uno de
los actores sobre todo nuestra política
es apoyar
incondicionalmente el marco de
discusiones que Kenia y Angola
establecieron también me entrevisté con
los dos presidentes Para apoyar las
mediaciones regionales que tuvieron
lugar de hecho apoyamos el despliegue de
las tropas kenianas de este que pudieron
instalarse
tuvimos la iniciativa diplomática de
hecho y en estos últimos ya se ha
hablado con el presidente para definir
todos estos procesos de negociación
regional sigo convencido de que la
respuesta debe ser colectiva Y ese es
precisamente el sentido de las
entrevistas que tendré con mis ojos
homólogos antes de llegar a kimsasa
una pregunta en videoconferencia
[Música]
Buenos días periodistas del libro para
la televisión
enciende usted que a pocos meses de la
elección presidencial aquí en gabón con
un sentimiento anti Francia que se
propaga en África occidental y que ya no
está aquí cree usted que su visita pueda
suscitar reacciones
lo comprendería si fuera un
desplazamiento electoral si fuera un
viaje con una finalidad estrictamente
bilateral o política
pero precisamente iremos al libro de vil
con una gran iniciativa internacional en
materia de biodiversidad con mis
ministros de acuerdo con lo que ya hemos
defendido en las cop y hacerlo en un
país
que tiene una posición de líder y que
está muy relajado muy afectado en este
tema
podríamos seguir definiendo el futuro de
los bosques primarios que están en Asia
Sur
Oriental en el río Congo en amazonia Yo
pienso que es mejor hacerlo con los
países afectados
su territorio
esta Cumbre es una con presencial sobre
los bosques para luchar contra la
deforestación la pérdida de
biodiversidad porque la presión sobre
los bosques tropicales es cada vez más
fuerte por eso con esta constatación y
con la agenda internacional que hemos
construido por eso escogimos gabón
organizando esta Cumbre para valorizar a
la riqueza de los bosques africanos que
el gran público conoce mal
asociar los demás países de la Cuenca
del Congo que juegan un papel esencial
Ese es el primer pulmón planeta la
Cuenca del Congo es el que secuestra la
mayor cantidad de carbono antes que a la
amazonia es también un depósito de vida
más de 240 millones de hectáreas y tiene
un tesoro inestimable de biodiversidad
eso es algo de lo cual hay que estar
orgullosos y hay que decirlo También
queremos crear un modelo que sea
adaptado para África y que no se ha
aportado como extraño por eso apoyamos a
quienes desarrollan soluciones y
apoyarlos científicos investigadores
gabón por ejemplo es un país que ha
sabido desarrollar un país una un
programa eficaz de gestión forestal y ha
construido
una economía que remunera mejor a su
población el objetivo de esta Cumbre y
por eso asumo plenamente hacerlo ahora
como fue nuestro compromiso en la última
cop
establecer los objetivos de las
diferentes luchar por esos y
fortalecer el capital natural en estas
economías Esta es una de las paradojas
sabemos remunerar la reforestación en
nuestros modelos nacionales e
internacionales pero no remuneramos bien
la protección de lo que tenemos
Y esto es lo que queremos establecer
será uno de los grandes ejes de esta
Cumbre fijar los parámetros de un
acuerdo justo entre los países
forestales y el resto de la comunidad
internacional con La Iniciativa de
relación o de asociación para una
conservación positiva que se resume en
un contrato entre un país forestal que
se compromete a proteger su naturaleza y
las reservas más vitales de Carbón y
biodiversidad a cambio de un apoyo más
importante de la comunidad internacional
todo esto es lo que vamos a hacer
y por eso voy a su país y por eso estaré
en libro Ese es el núcleo de esta
avanzamos trabajamos juntos no es un
viaje electoral le hablábamos a todo el
mundo incluso a los opositores Así mismo
iré después a Angola para hablar sobre
un tema de interés común que es la
seguridad alimentaria
es un programa que lanzamos desde que
comenzó la guerra en Ucrania somos el
primer socio de formación agrícola en
Angola entonces lanzaremos una
asociación en este
campo también iremos al Congo para
honrar la memoria de un lugar de
Renacimiento de nuestra política con
África y allí también tratar de defender
ese nuevo rumbo que acabo de explicar
acá
y luego iremos a la rdc para hablar de
los grandes temas de interés común salud
asociación económica temas de
infraestructura tec y también minería
cultura defensa porque somos el primer
socio de formación militar de la r